hemos amanecido aquí de nuevo con un
nuevo ataque con arma de fuego en
concreto esta vez ha sido en el
asentamiento de Ciudad de David en
Jerusalén este ocupado muy cerca de la
ciudad vieja como mencionabas lo que se
ha sabido es que ha habido dos heridos
varones de 47 y 23 años según los
paramédicos y según la prensa israelí se
trataría de un padre e hijo que por esas
heridas de bala en la parte superior del
cuerpo ahora se encuentran en condición
sería pero estable del atacante voy a
precisar que al principio se dijo que se
había neutralizado la policía había
dicho eso pero lo que se sabe es que ha
sido identificado como un adolescente de
13 años
residente de Jerusalén este en concreto
el barrio palestino de silán que fue
atacado por disparos por dos civiles que
lo neutralizaron ese momento que lo que
lo frenaron podemos decir pero ahora
mismo está haciendo atendido y está bajo
custodia policial y por todos estos
detalles la policía ha declarado de
nuevo el ataque como uno de carácter
terro qué es lo que se suele hacer
cuando hay agresores de origen palestino